bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre en direct sur notre
antenne
l'audition d'alexandre de juniac ce
c'est le pdg d'air france il est entendu
par les sénateurs dans un contexte bien
particulier puisque nous sommes en effet
au troisième jour d'une grève des
pilotes d'air france
ils protestent contre une proposition de
loi ump qui vise à encadrer le droit de
grève afin de mieux informer en amont
les passagers les pilotes demandent le
retrait de la principale disposition de
ce texte qui est examiné ce matin même
par la commission des affaires sociales
du sénat
principale disposition qui impose donc
aux grévistes de se déclarer
individuellement 48 heures à l'avancé
alors tout de suite place au direct pour
une matinée a tous bien monsieur le
président ne vous accueillons ici après
madame de kervillerm et que vous
connaissez sur site un rapport
remarquable qui a été fait au conseil
économique social et environnemental
présidée par monsieur delevoye est donc
la suite des auditions
je sais que ce matin vous devez être
très prix vous avez d'autres
préoccupations sur doute on veut on
imagine en tous les cas à n'est pas
vraiment des conditions climatiques il
peut y avoir un autre environnement qui
pourrait jouer j'occupais est en tous
les cas je vous laisse tout de suite la
parole pour présenter à la fois air
france klm enfin skyteam et c est donc
aussi bien sûr répondre que aux
questions de nos commissaires qui sans
doute vont est relativement nombreuse
par les temps qui courent vous avez
seule la parole monsieur le président
merci pierre hérisson je vous en prie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs je n'avais pas exposer trop en
détail pour ne pas pour ne pas enseveli
re la commission sous un excès de
l'excès de chiffres et de fait la
situation de la compagnie simplement
vous la décrire en quelques mots et qui
permettent d'expliquer pourquoi ce que
nous sommes dans la situation économique
difficile dans lequel accompagnait les
mesures que nous avons prises et le plan
de le plan de retour à l'équilibré de
développement que nous avons pour la
pour la maison comme vous savez le
transport aérien dans le monde et en
france est caractérisé par trois
tendances lourdes qui n'était pas celle
que qu'il connaissait il ya dix ans ou
qui se sont renforcées par avoir 7 10 à
10 ans la première c'est l'apparition
d'une concurrence très nouvelle qui pour
le groupe air france klm grignote lisant
la position d'air france klm comme des
compagnies historiques par le bas c'est
l'arrivée des low cost notamment sur son
réseau court et moyen-courrier phénomène
qui est mondial puisqu'il ya des low
cost européenne que vous connaissez ya
des low cost et dans l'amérique du nord
et du sud et en asie de deuxième
deuxième apparition une concurrence
extrêmement difficile pour nous sur le
long courrier apparition de compagnies
d'envergure mondiale qui sont
accompagnés du golfe dont les
contraintes économiques ne sont pas tout
à fait toujours les mêmes que les nôtres
et dont en tout cas l'agressivité
commerciale la compétence technique est
très grande et vient attaquer les parts
de marché les compagnies traditionnelles
sur des vols long courriers notamment
ceux pour nous la direction de l'asie
pour faire simple à grands traits
troisième but
troisième élément nous le leur france
klm est basée en zone euro et évidemment
les difficultés de la zone euro depuis
2008 accentué depuis maintenant quelques
quelques mois et les perspectives de
croissance ralentie de la zone euro
entre eux pèsent sur des perspectives de
trafic et puis évidemment sur le trafic
lui-même puisque que ce soit les
passagers venant des entreprises où les
passagers
qui qui sont sur des lignes pour des
raisons touristiques ou de loisirs
samson sont plus attentistes même si nos
chiffres actuellement pour les
engagements futurs ne sont pas trop
mauvais je tiens à le dire pour
l'instant
nous retenons notre souffle ce contexte
concurrentiel extrêmement difficile
c'est concurrentiel structurelles
difficiles c'est ce s'ajoutent deux
éléments conjoncturels important à prix
du pétrole qui est très élevé nous
étions ce matin à 116 116 dollars pour
pour le baril avec un euro qui elle qui
a plutôt baissé depuis
depuis quelques mois donc le prix
exprimés en euros ce qui nous intéresse
tous directement était un niveau
historiquement élevé
premier point de deuxième élément la
conjoncture économique hérité de 2008
fait que nous n'avons pas finalement
après le lol le choc subi en 2009
retrouvez évidemment et de loin les les
niveaux de trafic et les performances
économiques pour la maison ceci explique
que depuis quatre ans air france est
confrontée à une situation financière
extrêmement tendue je vois a caractérisé
par trois éléments
le premier c'est pour la quatrième année
consécutive le résultat d'exploitation
de la maison air france sera négatif est
sensiblement négatif
deuxièmement nous ne finançons pas
depuis quatre ans nos investissements
nous avons maintenu un niveau
d'investissement très élevé
je crois qu il faut à la fois s'en
féliciter puisque comme ça ont maintenu
le niveau à qualité notre appareil de
production
mais au détriment nos capacités
financières qui puisque la maison ne
génèrent pas suffisamment de cash flow
pour payer pour payer son développement
troisième élément et c'est la
conséquence la dette de la maison du
groupe air france klm a été multiplié
par plus de deux fois par deux et demi
trois presses quel passant d'un peu plus
de deux milliards et demi à 6 milliards
et demi en fin d'année 2011
donc nous sommes soumis à une contrainte
financière extrêmement forte à une
rentabilité insuffisante
ce qui explique notamment et je n'y
voyais pas là qu'elle compte que
révérence envers quelconque marché mais
une à une baisse très substantielle de
notre cours de bourse de plus de -70%
sur l'année 2011 ce qui nous met dans
une position qui est évidemment un peu
difficile quand il faut négocier avec
des partenaires ou utiliser le nos
actions si on veut payer en titres
notre monnaie pour l'instant n'est pas
assez évaluer la bonne air france c'est
ce qui explique que la mi janvier nous
avons présenté au cce un plan dit plan
de transformation de la maison air
france pourquoi plan de transformation
je m'arrête un instant sur ce mot il n'a
pas été choisie au hasard
il avait choisi au hasard puisqu'il ne
s'agit pas de prendre un ensemble de
mesures conjoncturelles pour redresser
le cap
ici pas d'un navire qui aurait qui
seraient temporairement sorti de la
route
il faut transformer la maison air france
pour améliorer structurellement sa
compétitivité pour qu'ils puissent faire
face aux enjeux structurels que j'ai
mentionné en introduction
ce n'est pas par des mesures temporaires
ou conjoncturels que nous pourrons
rester soi low cost soit en compagnie du
gauche soit faire face à la halle à une
conjoncture économique défavorable en
europe sont par des mesures
structurelles de réforme de la compagnie
de la compagnie air france ces mesures
pardon son vrai pour l'ensemble du
groupe air france klm elles sont
différentes pour air france et klm la
situation des deux maisons et n'étant
pas les mêmes n'ont pas la même pardon
sachant que le niveau d'effort demandé
aux deux est comparable
le plan transforme 2015 porte en effet
pour la maison air france sur le
rétablissement de 2 milliards 2
milliards d'euros de cash-flow ce qui
est un effort très très important pour
klm c'est environ 900 millions donc
l'ensemble de la lan semble de ce plan
permet une réduction de la dette de 2
milliards à l'horizon 2014
alors vous allez me dire pourquoi 2
milliards 9 alors qu'on veut réduire les
deux milliards simplement parce que nous
avons voulu prendre une provision pour
aller à au cas où le prix du pétrole
augmenterait au cas où la conjoncture de
sa possible je crois qu'il est sage un
secteur où le secteur est avec est très
cyclique qui est très dépendante
variable exogènes je cite deux variables
économiques je voudrais vu la plus
agréable climatique n'est pas totalement
négligeable non plus que la variable
technique est évidemment là parfois la
variable social mais je reviendrai
peut-être si vous voulez tout à l'heure
donc pour se prémunir de ces aléas nous
avons donc un plan extrêmement ambitieux
en termes de restauration à kbc
financière de deux autres objectifs nous
ont été assignés par le conseil
d'administration du groupe air france
klm
au delà de la réduction de la dette la
restructuration du réseau court et moyen
courrier qui concentre l'essentiel de
nos pertes même un volume plus important
que la perte du groupe compense et donc
par les meilleurs résultats que font
notre activité industrielle et notre
activité long courriers et d'autre part
le retour à la compétitivité générale de
la maison
ce plan transforme ce se décline en deux
phases
il durera sur trois ans la première
phase a été annoncée en 2015 et le coup
pendant certains nombres un rempart dont
aucun c'est le 15 janvier excusez-moi
2012 comporte
elle comporte trois séries de mesures
des mesures de
réduction ou de retardement de nos
investissements pour un montant
supérieur à 300 millions d'euros
il s'agit principalement des mesures qui
porte sur les investissements au sol et
sur le dd le report un certain nombre de
livraisons d'avions le tout pour essayer
de maintenir une flotte qui restent à un
niveau constant donc pas d'augmentation
de la flotte deuxième série de mesures
des mesures conjoncturelles puisqu'elle
devrait ne ne s'impose est que pendant
une durée limitée sur des mesures
principalement qui vise les coûts
salariaux le gel des salaires
ces mesures n'ont pas vocation à
perdurer au delà d'une période de deux
ans pourraient très précis sujet des
augmentations générales de salaires
et puis troisième élément des mesures
structurelles je voudrais citer une par
exemple sur des mesures d'économies de
carburant puisque le carburant pour la
formation de la commission c'est un
tiers de nos coûts voilà donc le
première série de mesures annoncées est
immédiatement applicable à mi janvier
une deuxième série de mesures est en
préparation et devrait être annoncée
dans le courant du printemps et de l'été
elle porte sur des mesures structurelles
de transformation notre réseau court et
moyen-courrier d'adaptation notre réseau
long-courrier d'adaptation de notre
hymne générique notre maintenance
d'adaptation de notre métier cargo par
ailleurs trois autres chantiers
horizontaux la productivité et
l'efficacité de nos méthodes de
production deuxièmement la la le
renouveau de nos méthodes de management
et d'organisation et troisièmement
l'investissement sur les produits et les
clients qu'il l'a la partie vraiment
développement de la maison pour l'avenir
parce que ce plan de retour à la
compétitivité et je vais en finir là il
a pour ce n'est pas une objectif en soi
c'est un moyen retrouver la
compétitivité pour air france dé revenir
à des résultats positifs à une à une
dette financière
limité à un cash flow positif c'est se
donner les moyens de retrouver la
croissance et le développement
l'objectif que nous avons assignés à air
france et au groupe air france klm à
l'horizon 2016 c'est de se retrouver
parmi les premiers mondiaux peut être le
premier à discuter sur le seul sur le
sur la place sachant que avec les
compagnies du golfe dont une a acheté 93
à 380 le nombre de passes elle 93 à 380
le nombre de passagers transportés
internationalement par cette compagnie
risque peut-être de dépasser celui d'air
france klm
donc je mets l'idée c'est 2016 le
leadership mondial
que ce soit en nombre de passagers
transportés peut-être ex-aequo avec une
autre et que ce soit en qualité de
service et un niveau de prestation pour
ça il faut que je retrouve capacités
financières en 2014 et que nous n'ayons
pas abandonner les investissements dans
deux domaines absolument clé pour la
compagnie et nous le faisons pas même
pendant ce plan d'économies de
redressement
les investissements sur la sécurité des
vols la sécurité au travail absolument
que les dents ça de notre maison et
l'investissement sur tout ce qui est lié
aux clients rénovation des cabines
amélioration des prestations à bord
rénovation des salons à terre voilà en
quelques en quelques mots pour ne pas
alourdir le les travaux de la commission
les grandes lignes de ce plan et je suis
fan nous sommes tout à fait disposés à
répondre à toutes les questions que la
commission pourrait avoir à l'esprit
merci monsieur le président
qu'on se comprenne bien enfin je sais
pas vous moi je m'attendais ce que vous
me fassiez me présenter c'est un petit
peu pédagogique je dirais entre air
france klm air france et skyteam et les
chiffres correspondants en termes de
chiffre d'affaires et de voir les enjeux
qui lie à derrière les deux si vous
pouvez avant de donner la parole aux
commissaires très bien non le groupe air
france klm césar air france klm
un groupe composé de deux compagnies
aériennes air france klm de compagnie
nationale air france pour la france klm
pour les pays bas et d'un certain nombre
de filiales qui sont les filiales
régionales pour air france régionale que
vous connaissez sans doute britair
airliner et cityjet et puis pour la
compagnie klm par city hopper ce sont
des compagnies mondiales qui opère une
flotte d'un petit peu moins de 600
avions longs et courts et moyens
courriers dans l'ensemble dans
l'ensemble d'un réseau international qui
est le plus dense et le plus développé
de l'ensemble des compagnies mondiales
air france klm de ce point de vue là se
ressemblaient se ressemblent par la
qualité et la densité de leur réseau
international air france par ailleurs
dispose d'un réseau court et moyen
courrier qui est beaucoup plus développé
que celui qu'elle aime notamment du fait
de la delà du territoire français qui
est beaucoup plus grand et qui est qu'il
est qu'il ya lieu de desservir ce que
klm est évidemment compte de la taille
du territoire hollandais moins en moins
à faire plus a vu des politiques dites
de hub c'est-à-dire de noeud de
communication alimentées par le réseau
court et moyen courrier qui ensuite
dispatch ses passagers sur des vols long
courriers centré sur deux hubs qui sont
roissy charles de gaulle pour air france
qui paul pour port klm sur la base ce ce
groupe donc air france klm constitué en
2000 cav est au centre d'un réseau
d'alliances avec des partenaires ce
réseau c'est le réseau skyteam dans les
principaux partenaires sont pour
l'amérique du nord delta qui est
maintenant la première compagnie au
monde en termes de nombre d'avions et de
passagers transportés
si on compte les passagers transportés
sur le territoire nord-américain
intérieur et à nouer
des à nouer des partenariats avec de
nombreuses compagnies européennes et
internationales au delà de delta
alitalia aeroflot
china southern et china eastern kenya
airways je ne devrais pas en oublier jeu
qu'orion saoudi donc voilà c'est l'idée
c'est de constituer un réseau de
partenariat mondial dont dans lequel les
partenaires s'échangent un certain
nombre un certain nombre de données
il opère des vols en commun ils
s'échangent des passagers les programmes
de fidélité sont mis en commun et ils
ont un certain nombre de prestations
communes dans les aéroports vous le
voyez peut-être sur les guichets ya
souvent des des grands panneaux marque
air france klm delta coréenne voilà donc
ils opèrent des moyens communs au sol et
7 à 10 ans skyteam étaient eux est une
des trois grandes alliances mondiales
qui est confronté à deux grandes
alliances concurrentes star alliance qui
est principaux me principalement menée
par lufthansa et la compagnie united
maintenant fusionner avec continental et
l'alliance oneworld qui est menée par
british airways avec american airlines
qui est une brillante contes animés qui
est actuellement sous chapitre 11 aux
etats unis c'est à dire on règlement
judiciaire s'il fallait reprendre
comparaison en droit français
voilà ces alliances sont un élément
évidemment est absolument déterminant du
développement d'air france klm que ce
soit évidemment sur l'amérique du nord
mais évidemment sur l'asie puisque nous
avons réussi à inclure dans le périmètre
de l'alliance china eastern et china
southern qui sont les deux premières
compagnies chinoises
il n'est pas venu pas être grand clerc
que de prévoir que la chine va avoir
probablement des compagnies à la mesure
du nombre d'habitants et de sa puissance
économique
un jour il y aura un milliard de chinois
qui vont voyager un jour voilà les gens
probablement à travers les compagnies
chinoises et on aimerait qu'ils voyaient
le travail des compagnies chinoises et à
travers air france est en tout cas dans
l'alliance skyteam
pour l'instant c'est pas si mal parti
que ça
que vous donner d'autres en terme en
termes de chiffres donc le le groupe air
france klm ses 25 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires à peu près un tiers
pour klm deux tiers pour air france ses
quatre métiers principaux ce qu'on
appelle le métier du passage c'est le
trafic de passagers
le métier du cargo trafic de fret nous
opérons une quinzaine d'avions tout
cargo plus d avion combinés s'éteint
c'est une activité qui est plus réduite
en chiffre d'affaires mais kate
importante compagnie air france klm plus
développés du côté hollandais que du
côté français la hollande étant une
plateforme logistique au quasi
européenne alors je mets importante
aussi sur la sur l'aéroport de charles
de gaulle c'est très complémentaire
une activité industrielle de khouzaa
plant engineering & maintenance qui
travaillent à aux deux tiers pour les
compagnies air france et klm et un tiers
pour des compagnies étrangères et qui
opère la maintenance des avions des
moteurs et des équipements qui se
développe à une vitesse assez grande
en france ses services à d'autres
compagnies compte tenu du niveau
technique du niveau de sécurité et du
niveau des installations industrielles
qui sont deux qui sont vraiment deux
probablement parmi ce qui se fait de
mieux dans sur 7 sur 7 sur cette terre
en matière de maintenance de qualité
industrielle très absolument remarquable
et puis que j'ai dû oublier un oui
pardon dans le métier passage nous
distinguons le le court et moyen
courrier qui est opérée sur des avions
dix ans de petite taille et le
long-courrier qui opéraient sur les
long-courriers airbus et boeing et qui
opère le réseau international hors
europe dont 4 nos quatre métiers dont un
le métier passage se divise en deux
merci monsieur le président la parole
j'ai 3 3 6 et 2 8 déjà demande de parole
va prendre une première salve est
et on va couper en deux oui donc
monsieur foucher le président simplement
une question qui concerne vos filiales
et notamment une bobo filiale créée
régional airlines détenue à 100% par
vous depuis sa création
et cette entreprise emploie je crois
1800 personnes aujourd'hui et elle
dessert un certain nombre de
destinations en france et 45
destinations
mais depuis quelques mois les résultats
de régionales sont fonction des lignes
que doit louer air france il semblerait
c'est ce qu'on explique que le réseau de
régionales sont en constante diminution
les lignes les plus rentables étant
récupérée par air france
donc ce qui nous intéresse c'est de
savoir comment les choses vont évoluer
un projet vous a mis en place basse
province qui a été adopté en accord avec
les syndicats des pilotes de ligne et il
semblerait que les salariés les pilotes
de regional airlines était exclue de cet
accord non ce qui m'intéresse de savoir
c'est l'avenir de regional airlines
naturellement et je ne sais pas si
original et un à la une ce concours
aussi aux appels d'offres on voit
beaucoup de compagnies anglaises sur le
territoire donc l'avenir de l'internet
c'est une question importante
monsieur capo canellas oui monsieur le
président d'abord merci de parler clair
parce que vous avez évoqué à la fois des
perspectives sur le moyen long terme qui
sont mobilisatrice et un plan ambitieux
de ce point de vue là et puis vous avez
évoqué sur le court terme des mesures de
redressement qui sont sans doute
douloureuse à mettre en place mais qui
témoigne d'une prise de conscience et
d'une mobilisation d'entreprises donc il
ya un attachement fort à la compagnie
sur les territoires aéroportuaires mais
au delà on peut que se féliciter de ces
deux ces deux points maintenant le
premier sujet que j'ai envie de
d'évoquer avec vous c'est comment
organiser le dialogue social comment
organisez-vous pour obtenir
l'acceptabilité de me
or qui sont douloureux je veux le dire
et qu'on comprend à sur le court terme
notamment
gl toute augmentation générale des
salaires cents de restructurations
les bases province et autres autre
mesure qui sont sans doute nécessaires
mais voilà comment organiser
l'acceptabilité de ce plan là et où
est-ce que vous en ai dû dire le social
il ya une grève en ce moment c'est pas
l'objectif des grévistes néanmoins ce
sujet là et quand même en toile de fond
donc voilà je crois que vous avez pris
des mesures sur le sujet on serait
curieux de savoir comment vous pouvez
gérer ce point là avec les partenaires
sociaux d'entreprise deuxième point vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure sur le long
terme de la station l'ingénierie la main
de temps ce qui est un sujet fort dans
la dans la compagnie voulait dire
l'instant que il y avait une excellence
industrielle alors on a tous en tête que
c'est un sujet majeur on vient de parler
d'industrie de recherche développement
tout à l'heure c'est un point ce cas la
france est présent on peut que s'en
féliciter
mais comment vous gérez la concurrence
avec l'étranger parce que les avions va
se déplacent par définition donc comment
faire pour que ce domaine la ré so
domaines d'excellence et je crois qu'il
ya des projets là dessus on peut que
vous soutenir dans cette démarche a mais
comment dessiner la perspective voilà ça
fait déjà 2 2 points importants
troisième sujet simplement ou est-ce
qu'on donnait sur le dossier alitalia
merci merci reparler terre roland
courteau
oui merci monsieur le président une
première remarque vous avez parlé
monsieur le président de la situation
financière et qui était particulièrement
tendue chiffre d'affaires de 25
milliards je crois savoir que les
investissements à chacun d'eux des sont
particulièrement importants pouvez-vous
dire de quel ordre
pouvez vous me dire également que les
pour air france klm la marge nette
je crois savoir qu'elle est relativement
faible
deuxième remarque la progression du
trafic pourraient se traduire au plan
mondial par un triplement du nombre de
passagers en 2030
cette progression est en effet liée à la
croissance du pib
comment vous y préparez vous troisième
remarque votre modèle de croissance
pourrait être menacée vous l'avez vous
même dit
un court et moyen courriers par les
compagnies à bas coûts et sur les
long-courriers par la puissance mentale
montante des compagnies dit du golfe et
vous seriez résonne d'ailleurs souligné
que émirats t avais je crois commandé
cinq airbus a380 pendant que air france
klm et lufthansa une quinzaine en cinq
ans il est vrai que les compagnies du
golfe comme la nièce un point de part de
marché alors si ce mouvement se poursuit
il pourrait aboutir à la perte de 11
mille emplois en europe question ne
faudrait-il pas je pense pas que vous me
contre l'isi là dessus ne faudrait-il
pas à porter une attention particulière
à l'ouverture de nouveaux droits de
trafic à ses compagnes et dit du golfe
en france et en europe et autre question
y aura-t-il des distorsions de
concurrence et lesquelles merci la
parole est un monsieur césar président
moi je voudrais rendre hommage la
qualité transport d'air-france pas
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui nous
sommes en pleine grève et ce qui est
très désagréable certain nombre de
collègues - utilisant l'avion les
navettes en particulier c'est
d'apprendre dernier moment que l'avion
ne part pas ça c'est très désagréable et
je suis sûr que vous même sur le
président vous pensez qu'il faut mettre
en place un service de prévention
concernant les grèves c'est c'est
l'objet aujourd'hui de la grève qui est
reconductible paraît-il mais vous avez
pas être information puisque l'on
aujourd'hui vous poser une question
monsieur le président par rapport
à ce qui concerne les alliances vous
avez parlé skyteam est ce qu'au niveau
du ciel européen
on pourrait pas imaginer beaucoup plus
de rapprochement et je passe d'un
particulier avec lufthansa qui peut-être
pour vous je demande un appoint d'un
important voilà les questions que je
voulais poser une surprise si le
président la dernière intervention dans
cette première salve philipp petzschner
et merci monsieur le président -
contrairement à mon collègue précédent
en tant que client évidemment je trouve
aussi très agréable
des histoires de grève de et de d'être
prévenus au dernier moment mais par
contre en tant que riverain
parfois c'est un vrai bonheur pour louer
on n'a jamais été on n'a jamais été
aussi heureux que pendant l'expo les et
l'éruption du volcan islandais donc
danser c'est pour faire une pointe
d'humour mais j'aimerais avoir votre
sentiment de président d'air france sur
la mise en place de la descente continue
qui est réclamée à cor et à cri par 6
millions de franciliens et sur lesquels
on a des réponses de la dg ac ou de
l'état qui sont un petit peu qui nous
laisse dubitatif
j'aimerais savoir votre avis de temps
qu'on a parfois des avis de pilote de
ligne en retraite ou un exercice qui
irait plutôt étonnant dans le sens de ce
qu'attendent les populations riveraines
merci merci monsieur le président vous
avez la parole pour ses cinq premiers
intervenants
je vous signale mes chers collègues en a
encore six derrière et donc oui mais il
y aura il y aura un décollage et
monsieur le président vous avez à
paroles merci besoin donc le régional et
est une de nos filiales qui opère qui
opèrent sur les lignes transversales
française et sur les lignes court
courriers
c'est une société qui opère son appel
des petits modules de notre jargon des
petits menus les petits avions s'il n'ya
aucunement péjoratif la danse simplement
cet événement 200 places un world ou
inférieurs ou égaux à 100 places
principalement des faits par embraer et
bombardier
il faut que vous ayez à l'esprit deux
choses le coût d'exploitation au siège
d'un petit module est le double de celui
d'un d'un a320
voilà ça c'est comme ça c'est la
contrainte technique de l'avion et donc
ce qui nous impose évidemment deux
choses de maintenir une politique de
prix qui est assez élevé puisqu'il faut
bien il faut bien compenser ce coût est
la seconde chose c'est de limiter ces le
développement des lignes de regionalps
avons aussi pour brit air le sueur sur
les lignes qu'ils ont sur lequel on peut
trouver des passagers capable de payer
bon prof pas de miracle là dessus donc
c'est ce qui explique peut-être le
sentiment vous avez eu de devoir
régional réduire son nombre de lignes
puisqu'ils ont été optimisés nombre de
lignes pour trouver les passagers qui
sont enfin un remplissage avec des
passages est capable de capable de payer
un billet disons au niveau que ne renie
pas les pas des coûts d'exploitation
il n'y a pas de cannibalisation d'air
france par régionales c'est pas le on
essaie de trouver le meilleur équilibre
en fonction des modules de chacune des
compagnies c'est vrai pour brit air pour
compléter la formation de la commission
si on met des turboprop le coût baisse
au profit des avions à hélice pardon je
suis con fait 2-2 juste jargon le coût
au siège diminuent sensiblement et
d'ailleurs doit être probablement
inférieur à celui des avions à réaction
même des a320 seulement commercialement
c'est très difficile parce que les
passagers n'aime pas ça enfin certains
nombre de passagers en sont folles des
jets et ne va donc vous voyez nous
sommes entre compromis à trouver
outre le fait que les turbos propre sont
plus lents donc mais nous sommes aussi
en position de gérer au mieux le
compromis entre prix confort des
passagers
mais on une cabine ou ne cannibalise ont
pas une compagnie par l'autre ceci dit
et c'est pour la formation de la
commission régionale comme brit air
comme cityjet comme airliner se font
partie de notre réseau court et moyen
courrier dans le projet de
restructuration de notre réseau court et
moyen courrier qui comprend ces quatre
compagnies
plus les avions d'air france qui opère
le réseau court et moyen courrier elles
sont inclus et on va regarder comment ce
qu'on optimise l'ensemble voilà puisque
c'est notre principal foyer de pertes
malheureusement voilà sur le thème si je
peux compléter les bases province
effectivement sont venus substituer
quelquefois des lignes opérées par
région adeline progrès opéré par
régional dé mieux préparés france
l'accord qui a été passé avec régional a
été de remplacer nombre pour nombre les
lignes en question par d'autres lignes
qui ne paieraient pas auparavant
pour le reste régionale bénéficie de
tout la porte et roissy puisque il
s'occupe de transversale d'un côté il
faut être en deçà d'un côté et de
l'autre côté ils font des vols d'apport
sirois ci est globalement leur rythme
leur activité je penserai dernière sur
roissy a évolué au même rythme que les
correspondances long courriers c'est à
dire positivement
enfin comme des problèmes sociaux se
pose et je pense à la base de marseille
nous avons eu un accord avec régional de
telle sorte que les personnes qui t'a
régional et qui souhaitaient venir à air
france on tue je pense à des pnc puisque
leurs bases de province sont
essentiellement gratuit par les
personnels navigants commerciaux ont eu
la possibilité d'intégrer la france ils
ont subi une sélection privilégiée sur
les cases qui était à marseille 12 ont
intégré la compagnie air france donc
nous avons des échanges réguliers et
donc pour les autres bases ce qui se
passera de la même manière vous pouvez
demander ensuite comment ce que nous
organisions le dialogue social c'est un
sujet assez vaste vous pouvez l'imaginer
dans la société air france il est
organisé autour
le pilier de ce dialogue social et jean
claude cros qui la mêlée pendant des
années je pense complétera c'est la
construction d'accord avec les
organisations professionnelles qui
représentent les différentes catégories
de personnels donc il ya un cadre il ya
un cadre contractuel extrêmement
extrêmement riche à ses anciens il ya
dizaine d'accords sur divers sujets
d'aider des conventions qui qui qui
organise le dialogue social
l'objet de la delà de notre plan de
transformation
c'est pas du tout de remettre en cause
ce dialogue social c'est de bâtir un
nouveau cadre contractuel qui soit
adaptée nouveau modèle économique
nous sommes en train de bâtir un nouveau
modèle économique pour faire face aux
pays du golfe
low cost tout ce qu'on dit est ce là ils
exigent face à cela à nouveau cadre
contractuel en matière sociale avec
probablement des efforts de productivité
avec probablement une plus grande
flexibilité et tout ça sera négocié au
sein d'accor avait des relations
professionnelles pour faire cela nous
avons souhaité et nous allons proposer
aux instances du personnel
le 10 février c'est à dire vendredi
prochain un projet de dénonciation des
conventions projet de dénonciation qui
ne vise pas du tout à détruire le cadre
contractuel mais à le rénover et
simplement c'est un des moyens il y en a
d'autres que nous avons que nous avons
choisie pour expliquer à l'ensemble des
personnels et des relations
professionnelles que de lance que les
accords doivent être regardées dans leur
intégralité et que nous n'avons et que
nous devons limiter le temps de la
renégociation il faut renégocier
nous n'avons pas beaucoup le temps
malheureusement personnellement je
souhaiterais avoir du temps et j'aurais
préféré éviter avoir à passer par ces
étapes mais quand on on a un résultat
d'exploitation négatif plusieurs
centaines de millions pour quatrième
année consécutive je pense qu'il est
temps de il est temps de prendre le
sujet à bras le corps et il n'est plus
temps de tergiverser
nous voulons organiser la négociation
dans un laps de temps le plus réduit
possible
voilà c'est ça qui nous guide un bien
sûr et donc un nouveau cra de
contractuels le plus rapidement mis en
place avec les relations syndicales dans
transparence il n'a rien voulu cacher
rien nous nous donnerons tous les benchs
par toutes les comparaisons pour que le
niveau des efforts à faire soit reconnue
accepté et est partagé par l'ensemble
des personnels nous avons imposé
également une prospérité à tous les
niveaux hiérarchiques de la société à
commencer par votre serviteur et par la
direction générale
voilà puisque il était nécessaire que
nous montrions l'exemple je sais pas si
tu veux compléter ce oui il n'est pas
question de mettre à bas de la politique
contractuelle d'air france qui est une
politique ancienne et nourris je
rappelle que nous venons de signer y
compris pendant cette période ajouté
un accord sur le handicap qui est le
huitième du genre d'accord sur
l'alternance qui est le sixième du genre
sans d'un corps triennaux un accord sur
la formation triennal un accord sur les
bases province
quand on parlait tout à l'heure un
accord qui doit être une première du
genre sur les risques psychosociaux donc
sur la souffrance au travail sur la
légalité homme femme qui est le sixième
aussi que nous ayons d'un corps triano
bref la politique contractuelle
elle n'est pas mise à bas par les
mesures de restriction nous sommes allés
pas prendre
deuxième chose les mesures nous avons à
prendre ne vise pas à modifier ou à
réduire les éléments substantielle du
contrat de travail
il s'agit de nous améliorer sur deux
domaines
nous avons d'un côté une pente
d'évolution de nos salaires de manière
quasi automatique qui est trop fort
qu'il est depuis de nombreuses années et
nous avons de notre côté un temps de
travail effectif qui mérite d'être
amélioré
ce sont sur ces deux aspects qui ne
touchent pas ni le salaire de base des
personnes ni les éléments substantiels
contre un travail que nous souhaitons
avec les partenaires sociaux progresser
faut savoir que nous avons des accords
qui datent pour certains d'entre eux
depuis le début des années 70 c'est une
longue stratification et donc le volume
des dénonciations que nous faisons peut
donner sentiment que nous allons
bouleverser le paysage contractuels nous
allons simplement le réformer
dans l'esprit contractuels qui préside à
la maison depuis toujours gérer la
concurrence industrielle donc nos
activités industrielles gère trois
catégories de deux trois catégories
d'activités la maintenance dit avions
fuselage pour faire simple la
maintenance moteurs et la maintenance
des équipements le autant la maintenance
moteurs et la maintenance des
équipements sur les activités à très
haute valeur ajoutée lequel la la la
l'outil la qualification des personnels
et la qualité technique de l'outil est
absolument déterminante et la france je
ne peins venant l'industrie aéronautique
je me permettait d'avoir quelques
lumières sur la question j'ai rarement
vu un outil industriel de ce niveau pour
la maintenance du fuselage là aussi nous
avons aussi de pousser notre outil
industriel au meilleur niveau mais si tu
mets cela la concurrence des pays des
pays
à bas salaires et des puisque je suis
l'industrie de madoff est plus forte
nous essayons d'optimiser sa au mieux
raison de maintenir sur le territoire
français que ce soit à paris dans les
bases industrielles que nous avons ou à
toulouse le le maximum le maximum
d'activités après avec nos partenaires
nous essayons de voir s'ils peuvent
amener des avions chez nous ou si il
faut que nous installions aux activités
industrielles chez eux ce que vous
imaginez les avions se déplacent mais
s'il faut qu'il fasse de long trajet
pour venir se faire entretenir c'est un
coût supplémentaire donc voilà le type
de le type de compromis que nous
essayons de gérer
pour l'instant je crois ça s'est fait au
mieux
alitalia vous savez qu air france klm 2
à 25% dans le capital d'alitalia
alitalia qui a connu un retournement
absolument spectaculaire suite à une
quasi faillite et au passage par ce qui
ressemble à un chapitre 11 à l'italienne
si je puis dire la compagnie alitalia
maintenant est revenu au meilleur niveau
nous avons 25 % avec un maquereau
d'actionnaires qui est qui bloque le
tour de table jusqu'en janvier 2013 puis
à janvier 2013 le tour de table
les actionnaires italiens ne sont plus
liés par cet accord la compagnie
alitalia tout le management de la
compagnie alitalia souhaite fusionner
avec air france klm et le ils le disent
ils le répètent nous nous souhaiterions
évidemment poursuivre poursuivre dans ce
dans cette voie si les capacités
financières ou le cours de l'action air
france klm ne sont pas suffisantes à ce
moment-là nous espérons trouver tous les
moyens pour conserver à l'italienne en
gironde air france klm et concrétise une
opération financière et vous voyez bien
encore une fois ne pas disposer des
capacités financières que ce soit en
argent ou avoir un cours de l'action qui
est trop bas nous empêche tout
simplement d'avoir les moyens de faire
une opération qui est stratégique pour
nous aussi donc c'est bien la finalité
du plan la première partie du plan de
transformation de l'association la
compétitivité nos investissements se
sont situées à un niveau supérieur à 2
milliards d'euros par an
c'est ce qui nous a permis d'avoir une
flotte au meilleur niveau l'âge moyen de
la flotte d'air france est un petit peu
moins de 9 ans actuellement donc c'est
c'est plutôt une flotte jeune avec des
avions qui sont non seulement moderne
adapté être que demandent les passagers
mais avec des consommations carburant et
d et des qualités techniques ils nous
mettent au meilleur niveau
nous pensons qu'il faut réduire ce
niveau d'investissement assez
sensiblement pendant les trois
prochaines années pour restaurer donc
nos capacités financières je n'ai eu que
cette réduction a été calculée de
manière
premièrement elle a été calculée de
manière à maintenir la qualité de
l'outil de production
nous ne mettons pas en cause ni les
ateliers ni la qualité des avions
sa première chose et la deuxième chose
nous avons essayé de préserver comme
valeur les secteurs qui nous paraissait
essentiel au développement futur la
compagnie sécurité des vols et
investissements dans tout ce qui est lié
aux clients je voudrais dire que le
niveau d'investissement antérieures des
quatre dernières années notamment qui
restaient très élevés ce qui explique la
dette
je me suis permis de dire au début me
permet de dire que la réduction
envisagée sur les trois prochaines
années ne sera pas préjudiciable à air
france elle porte sur le niveau de la
face aux assauts sur le nombre d'avions
donc nous décalons sur sambre
d'investissement au sol sur son
investissement technique mais on avait
dit long la compagnie avait bien investi
jusque là elle était plutôt confortable
donc voila nous serons un peu moins
confortable sans pénaliser l'outil de
production
vous avez demandé une question sur la
marge nette de la de la société là bas
alors je ne peux pas vous la donner pour
2011 les comptes et non pas encore
certifiées ni ni ni repas été présenté
au conseil mais la marge nette est
plutôt négative de la du groupe air
france klm
en ce qui concerne le trafic le
triplement du trafic à l'horizon 2030
est effectivement assez probable quand
vous savez c'est le trafic augmente plus
vite que la croissance économique
il augmente un peu comme le commerce
mondial est probablement un tout petit
peu plus vite
le triplement malheureusement ou
heureusement enfin je pense que ce
triomphe place
il est vrai mais il se fera pas en
europe oui oui nous sommes justement
dans le monde donc il va se faire dans
des zones qui sont plutôt évidemment la
zone asie la zone amérique latine
probablement l'afrique
donc pour nous ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire deux choses ça veut dire qu'il faut
que nous développions les partenariats
que nous avons avec des compagnies
locales voire peut-être des
implantations locales
peut-être que à horizon 10 ou 15 ans les
grandes compagnies internationales
seront des compagnies qui auront des
hubs mondiaux sur les deux grands
continents c'est pas impossible
j'attire l'attention sur le fait
qu'actuellement les réglementations de
l'oaci rendre ça très difficile
puisqu'elles sont très protectrices
leurs compagnies nationales ça a été le
l'essence même de la construction la
construction de l'aviation civile
internationale après la guerre la la la
deuxième
le deuxième moyen de différents facettes
à partir de 2014 je pense si nous
retrouvons le chemin de la croissance
c'est de conserver un niveau
d'investissement pour développer notre
réseau international notamment un niveau
d'investissement avion qui nous
permettent de répondre à l'augmentation
de ce trafic
en ayant les meilleurs avions possible
la meilleure destination le modèle de
croissance vous avez à trouver sur
modèle de croissance
je voulais revenir un instant sur ce
point on a un modèle de croissance qui a
marché jusqu'aux la fin d'année de la
première décennie des années 2000 on on
y est là et qui était fondée dans les
années 90 sur l'idée suivante s'est
proposée de la croissance rentable
c'est à dire que la croissance était
suffisante pour absorber ce que
notamment jean claude kross a évoqué
tout à l'heure qui sont la hausse des
coûts actuellement on a un
ralentissement de la croissance plus
l'arrivée de nouveaux concurrents
donc notre modèle économique antérieures
doit être doit être doit être
profondément transformé dit autrement
avant nous faisions de la croissance
pour être rentable maintenant il faut
que nous soyons productif pour être
rentable et faire de la croissance
leleu et c'est pour ça qu'on a engagé le
plan sans sommation
je crois que l'ensemble des personnels
de la maison en est conscient c'est donc
productivité compétitivité afin de
restaurer les marges financières pour
retrouver la croissance et c'est dans ce
sens là que nous avons inversé
donc je pense qu'il est nécessaire qu'on
inverse le modèle de croissance alors
vous avez évoqué la perte potentielle
d'emplois qui est qui serait provoquée
par la concurrence de compagnies de
compagnies du golfe
enfin ou de diverses compagnies non
cotées dans les compagnies du golfe
alors le chiffre j'habite à la prudence
sur le cheese je sais pas s'il a fait
part des emplois ce qui est vrai c'est
que nous nous pensons qu'une concurrence
déloyale une concurrence qui ne serait
pas loyal venant de compagnies qui n'ont
pas les mêmes contraintes économiques
que nous fait globalement perdre des
emplois à la france même si on compte
les emplois supplémentaires générés par
la générés par la vente d'airbus
le sol est légèrement négatif le solde
légèrement négatif
donc il ya un compromis à trouver entre
les droits trafic demandés par les
compagnies qui achètent massivement des
arbitres je rappelle qu'il demande la
même chose aux américains et que no no
no no partenaire american delta ont la
même préoccupation vis-à-vis de leur
autorité pour les mêmes raisons dans la
même situation le gouvernement
maintenant sont très vigilants de
l'octroi de droits de trafic puisque
vous savez que c'est comme ça que le que
le système est régulée dans la plupart
des pays du monde sauf en angleterre qui
a conclu avec les pays du golfe des
accords d'open sky à la sortie des
années 60 et des haies et les british
airways a effectivement vu ses parts de
marché d'autre elle s'écroulait je
rappelle juste pour la formation de
l'après-vie sûr il existe un manchester
dubaï par a380
petit exemple révélateur
vous avez ensuite le jeu mentionner la
difficulté pour les passagers des
annulations dit à chaud alors je là je
pars dont je pourrais défendre la
compagnie dans ce conflit là ce que nous
avons fait des efforts considérables
pour informer les passagers
les passagers en avance et donc c'est ce
qui nous a amenés à faire deux choses
d'abord nous avons développé des outils
informatiques et de communication vous
avez peut-être hors expérimenté vous
même vous recevez des mails et des sms
pour vous expliquer l'état de votre vol
à l'avance sachez que nous envoyons près
de près de pure dizaines de milliers de
mails et de sms par jour en ce moment
pour avertir nos passagers nous avons
fait une deuxième chose c'est que nous
avons abattu notre programme à froid à
l'avance nous avons annulé un certain
nombre de vols est averti les passagers
et re router les passagers soit sur nos
partenaires soient sur d'autres vols
c'est ce qui explique où l'avez vu dans
le conflit actuel qu' il y est
extrêmement peu d'encombrement pour
l'instant dans les aéroports il y a et
joue et on se donne en mai je sais on a
mis en place sachez simplement que ce
que c'est ces mesures d'abattement de
programmes de reroutage de renforts dans
les aéroports coûte une dizaine de
millions d'euros à la compagnie par jour
dans la situation dans lequel nous
sommes je trouve que c'est assez malvenu
voilà en sus de ces mesures nous sommes
malheureusement et tous les jours et on
le regrette beaucoup
obligé de procéder à de la nation dit à
chaud où les passagers sont là et où les
équipages ne sont pas présentés
notamment notamment notamment les
personnels navigants techniques
c'est d'ailleurs une des raisons de la
proposition de loi qui va être soumis à
votre examen dans quelques jours qui est
que de demander au personnel de se
déclarer 48 heures avant c'est pour nous
une manière de nous organiser puisque
les estimations de programmes que nous
faisons la veille et sachez que nous y
participons tous les soirs et tous les
matins on a une réunion de prévision de
programme pour la journée du lendemain
ne ne peuvent se faire que ce soit des
estimations et part évidemment nous
corrigeant nos estimations le jour même
par l'emploi de réserve mais ces
réserves ne sont pas infinies voit la
question suivante vous avez évoqué les
alliances et des rapprochements européen
alors comme vous le voyez en europe
maintenant il ya trois grandes
compagnies dites majeures d'aller beauty
sherweb iberia ensemble la lufthansa qui
a une constellation de compagnie autour
d'elle avec austrian et swiss
et puis il ya air france klm air france
klm ils ont montré le chemin en réalité
de l'a27 de ces rapprochements européen
il y at-il matière rapprochement
supplémentaires je pense que c'est
beaucoup trop tôt pour le dire
je ne suis pas sûr qu'en termes de
concurrence il soit possible de
rapprocher deux très grandes mais dors
je pense qu'il y aura une vraie
difficulté de concurrence on le voit aux
états unis la situation est comparable
vous avez trois grandes compagnies
american airlines vous avez continental
united et vous avez delta le le fait qu'
american airlines soit en faillite à
amener les autres à regarder à potentiel
rachat et on voit que la question de
concurrence devient très difficile
passée de 3 à 2 je dois dire c'est un
jeu enfin je pense qu'il faut être
prudent
dernier point sur la descente continue
zone continue vue de vue des refontes
sommes plutôt favorable à descendre
continue maintenant il ya des conditions
de régulation de trafic d'encombrement
et de sécurité des vols qui font que la
dg assez légitimement considère que
c'est un sujet à regarder deux avec avec
soin avant de se lancer dans la descente
continue mais pour nous évidemment en
termes d'économies de carburant c'est
très favorable et et de raccourcis pour
des vols mais ensuite et de bruit ono et
de brume mais ça c'est plus je crois
pour les riverains que monsieur le
sénateur représentant auquel nous sommes
sensibles mais pour nous c'est le la
rapidité et l'économie de carburant est
évidemment aussi la voilà un monsieur le
président j'ai six demandes les paroles
encore monsieur denis ce qui est sans
doute décollé de nice
un certain nombre de questions déjà été
posés ça me permettra d'être plus court
d'autant plus qu'à 12 heures j'ai naudy
sur ce pôle de compétitivité donc
monsieur le président je vous prie par
avance destrier le fait que je ne
pourrais pas il as écouté votre réponse
mais je vais lire et dans le compte
rendu
trois éléments le premier étant élu
local plus d'un des dunes des communes
qui accueillent votre site
sophia antipolis valbonne sophia
antipolis je connais je peux mesure au
quotidien l'attachement des personnels
d'air france à leur compagnie et ne
pensez vous pas qu'il ya une
contradiction dans le fait que vous
puissiez dans un même mouvement nous
dire que depuis plusieurs années la
situation financière se dégrade qu' il y
a un problème de modèle économique d'un
problème structurel
par ailleurs avec un propos dans la
réponse où vous nous dites que le niveau
d'investissement antérieures explique la
dette donc la dette serait telle
provoquées par des investissements
ailleurs trop élevé au plus
structurellement par un modèle
économique vieillissant et face à ça
vous expliquez nous avons plus le temps
de tergiverser
pas de négociation en fait possible
ceci par rapport davet jeu cette
question-là m'apparaît centrale la
responsabilité à un moment donné de
décisions qui n'ont pas été prises en
son temps on peut le comprendre mais
forcément cela va peser et vous en avez
souligné l'urgence des mesures à prendre
donc cela va forcément peser dans le
dialogue social et être une rupture par
rapport à les pratiques qu'il y avait
dans la maison air france klm
n'avez vous pas une crainte majeure à la
matière quels sont les éléments qui vont
permettre qu'il y ait un bon partage au
delà des informations mais aussi du
caractère stratégique des décisions à
prendre
excusez moi du peu le modèle économique
pour les années à venir
le deuxième élément monsieur denis si
vous pouviez faire court je peux partir
ce prénom mais en l'occurrence je vais
essayer d'être très synthétique
le deuxième élément c'est l'avenir de
l'informatique dans l'avenir de
l'informatique dans le groupe
le troisième élément c'est parents
beauport amadeus
quelle est votre stratégie sachant que
dans un premier temps vous avez réalisé
une opération particulièrement
intéressante
allez vous poursuivre dans ce sens et à
terme un désinvestissement de d'amadeus
ou poursuivre votre participation
amadeus qui elle un modèle économique
particulièrement intéressant merci
merci monsieur le président moi je
savais être rapide puisque ma question
portait sur le dialogue social alors
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de j'avais eu
l'occasion de faire un stage d'une
semaine à l'intérieur de votre groupe
il y a quelques années
et votre vos réponses m'ont satisfaite
je voudrais quand même toutefois
m'attarder sur les difficultés avec les
compagnies low cost oil âgé d'à peine à
comprendre
easyjet et etc comment nous n'arrivions
pas ou comment votre groupe n'arrive pas
à détacher ou par une filiale a quand
même à se mettre au même niveau parce
que et il apporte un service alors leur
service et il nettement moins de moins
bonne qualité que le vôtre donc on joue
sur la qualité on jure sur la sécurité
on joue sur le service à bord bien sûr
mais on est capable on reconnaît
l'excellence du service air france et
les reconnu dans le monde entier mais on
est aussi capable d'aller sur ce terrain
là on doit pouvoir et y faire face et là
je comprends pas que on a des
difficultés
merci monsieur vaugrenard oui merci
monsieur le président on a tous compris
que la situation était complexe et
surtout très préoccupante avec une marge
net négatif et une augmentation de la
dette
ketty millet par 3 d'une année sur
l'autre j'ai bien compris qu'il était
nécessaire probablement de négocier de
négocier vite
l'inconvénient parfois des négociations
trop rapide c'est le risque d'arriver à
des conflits par rapport à cela est ce
que vous ne me répondre sur le risque
éventuel de délocalisation d'une partie
de l'entreprise d'air france très très
précisément vous avez indique également
que le carburant présenter un tiers du
coût ce qui bien entendu est est
important notamment avec un baril du
pétrole qui augmentent et un cours de
l'euro qui diminue donc c'est double
peine en quelque sorte
quels sont les moyens qui vous
permettent de gérer cet aspect des
choses c'est que c'est très compliqué
vous avez indiqué que
l'âge moyen des avions était de 9 années
donc a priori il ya moins de
consommation de carburant avec les
avions plus récent que les plus anciens
et enfin la perte d'air france est dû
sans but il essentiellement court et
moyen courriers qu'est-ce qu'il ya des
risques de diminution de trafic ou de
lignes supprimées parce que ce nous
intéresse fortement dans le cas de
l'attractivité de nos différents
territoires
difficile et pourtant c'est quand même
des secteurs stratégiques donc quelle
stratégie vous imaginez pour ce secteur
d'autant plus il ya de la concurrence
avec le maritime
deuxièmement vous nous avez déjà répondu
sur la question industrielle mais
j'insiste en même lourdement
j'ai bien entendu ce que vous dites en
filigrane sur le sur le fuselage sur le
fait que quand même
air france n'est pas n'importe quelle
entreprise en france et qu'il me semble
quand même qu'il faut combattre au
maximum les risques de faire travailler
à l'étranger nos activités industrielles
et ça me ramènera tout à l'heure sur la
question du capital troisièmement vous
parlez de des baisses de crédits
d'investissement mais tous les secteurs
peuvent pas être traités de la même
manière je pense à secteurs comme
l'informatique mon collègue d'aunis en a
parlé
quand on a un secteur informatique tons
bleus ont réduit de 11% investissement
là on a tout de suite une perte de
compétitivité ou de d'efficacité parce
que on se trouve avec la nécessité d'un
secteur d'évoluer très vite on s'est
quand même la politique commerciale
d'air france est un élément tout à fait
l'essentiel donc je je me permets de
dire que je voulais savoir quel était
votre stratégie dans la diversité des
efforts à faire selon les
investissements ensuite les secteurs
géographiques
mais ça recoupe un peu ce qu'a dit notre
collègue vaugrenard ou ce qu'a dit marc
daunis quid de la plateforme d'orly
est-ce que vous avez des stratégies de
modification de vos sites de vos sites
géographiques
est-ce que sur l'informatique toulouse
valbonne il ya des risques de
modification et puis il ya autour du
débat qui est très important sur la
concurrence avec les pays du golfe
toutes les questions des hubs c'est à
dire comment les aubes régionaux
pourraient ou non être utilisé par les
compagnies du golfe pour commencer à
favoriser leur entrée en france en tout
cas plus qu'elles ne le sont aujourd'hui
enfin je termine le capital d'air france
pouvez vous nous dire à peu près quelle
est la masse de dividendes qui était v
c'est dans les dix dernières années aux
actionnaires privés d'air france parce
que j'entends bien que votre valeur
capitalistique a baissé mais on sait que
le transport aérien est cyclique alors
pour avoir été riveraine d'une mère
d'une ville où un air inter étaient déjà
installés donc je suis depuis de très
longues années ce sujet et j'entends
cycliquement tous les 5 10 ans les mêmes
sujets qui reviennent cycliquement et on
ma toujours expliqué que dans le
transport aérien le capital n'était pas
rentable de manière continue de la même
manière ce qui de mon point de vu avait
toujours pesé pour qu'à une part de
capital public soit importante dans les
compagnies pour qu'elle ne soit pas
vulnérable aux aléas de la conjoncture
donc je voulais savoir quelle stratégie
vous avez quant à l'avenir de votre
capital
est-ce que vous souhaitez que la part de
l'état puisse être renforcée est ce que
vous imaginez des distributions
d'actions gratuites à vos salariés et
par ailleurs je reprends la question de
notre collègue sur amadeus
car ils vous échappe pas qu'il ya
aujourd'hui air france à 15% environ
d'amadeus a fait pas tout à fait un
milliard huit cent quatre-vingt-dix
mille et un million d'euros est ce bien
nécessaire d'y rester et n'est-il pas
utile d'utiliser cet argent pour
d'autres investissements
merci là des questions concise
comment les deux dernières monsieur
bourquin et ensuite monsieur testons le
président des questions simples et
directes vous nous avez dit que la
situation d'air france nécessité des
mesures et cela fait consensus dans
l'ensemble du monde syndical
simplement il ya une question qui
revient lancinante pourquoi travailler
en deux temps esca pas là derrière un
temps politique qui se cache
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on a un temps post
élections présidentielle et législatives
est ce qu'il y aura l'essentiel du plan
qui arrivera en juin
oui je ne vais pas part
36 des tours un deuxième question vous
nous dit tout à l'heure la situation
d'air france nécessite des mesures et
tout le monde en est persuadé
vous ajoutez avec ces mesures dans
quelques années on peut se retrouver
dans les tous premiers mondiaux est ce
que c'est une volonté de se retrouver et
tout premiers mondiaux et ce qu'il faut
pas une compagnie nationale et
internationale attractive
plutôt que de vouloir jouer toujours
toujours dans les premiers de la classe
est ce que là c'est pas une déformation
parce que pour être un client d'air
france régulier comme beaucoup de nos
collègues l'importance de l'attractivité
de la qualité de services d'une
compagnie est fondamental pour justement
un train parce que le retour à
l'équilibré ne viendra pas simplement
des économies via rassure les nouvelles
parts de marché et l'attractivité et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut l'augmenter
cette attractivité
dernière chose excusez moi je suis
encore un peu plus direct on parlait de
de commande économie on parlait de
d'efforts du personnel est ce qu'il sera
partagé par tous est ce qu'il sera juste
et j'ai vu que comment il y avait un
appel au grand salaire très hauts
salaires qui demandait à être
ponctionnées est ce que tous les
salaires et notamment les hauts salaires
parce que je pense que les hauts
salaires d'air france le husa l'air
d'air france est assez c'est un prof
important montrera vous savez quand moi
je suis maire d'une ville
si jamais je ne montre pas l'exemple
c'est fait comme je dis pas comme je
fais et de ce point de vue really a en
france une une vraiment rue une comment
une situation qui devient intolérable où
c'est toujours les mêmes qui font les
efforts et rarement ceux qui t'ont sont
au dessus d'une échelle voilà je pense
que si ce plan de retour à l'équilibré
doit fonctionner il doit inévitablement
adhère entraîner l'adhésion du personnel
il faut qu'ils soient profondément juste
michel teston pour finir oui monsieur le
président à ma connaissance il était
prévu une intégration plus importante de
klm dans la structure commune air france
klm avec la nouvelle organisation il
semblerait j'emploie le conditionnel que
cette dernière étape de la fusion entre
air france et klm soit remise à plus
tard
est ce que cette remarque et est fondée
qu'en est il réellement pouvez vous nous
éclairer à ce sujet merci monsieur le
président vous avez la parole pour finir
pour conclure avant réponses aux
différentes questions plus ou moins
directe de nos collègues
alors si concerne l'avenir de
l'informatique qui répond à deux de vos
collègues ou ce président pardon sera un
monsieur qu'est partie l'informatique
pour une compagnie aérienne
c'est absolument clé s'est créé pour son
exploitation ses clés pour sa relation
client puisque vous savez que maintenant
je donne ce chiffre est intéressante
nous faisons 30 % de nos ventes par
internet
delta en fait 75 donc on voit bien la
tendance ya pas d ya pas d rate là ça ne
veut pas dire que ça veut pas dire que
par derrière une fois il ne faut pas les
effectifs importants de support ça veut
dire que l'outil informatique pour la
vente devient quelque chose d'absolument
clé on a parlé des systèmes que nous
appelons en bon français de recovery
c'est ce que c'est ce système que nous
mettons en oeuvre actuellement pour
informer nos passagers en cas de
problème la grève en ce moment ça peut
ne pas l'y matic tout tous ces systèmes
sont basées sur l'informatique donc
l'informatique c'est absolument clé dans
la maison ce qui est vrai c'est que nous
avons baissé notre budget informatique
en essayant de ne pas toucher à deux
catégories d'applications les
applications qui tournent pour le pour
améliorer l'exploitation de la maison et
les nouveaux développements qui vit
nouvelles technologies pour les clients
par exemple fait de pouvoir faire
beaucoup de choses à travers ce l'objet
que je tiens à la main qui sont les
smartphones exemple de mai il
l'informatique n'a pas échappé non plus
aux programmes d'économies je pense pour
connaître pardon un tout petit peu ce
sujet là que nous gérions peut être un
trop grand nombre de projets en même
temps et que le resserrement des
priorités était nécessaire sans mettre
en cause encore une fois la
compétitivité de la maison ni son
efficacité mais je dois même dire que le
personnel dans son ensemble je parle pas
de danse à l'informatique le personnel
dans son ensemble demandé un
ralentissement de rythme des projets car
les changements étaient trop nombreux en
même temps donc ça n'était pas du tout
incompatible avec le souhait général de
la compagnie et pour avoir dans ma vie
précédente fait beaucoup de techniques
et vendu beaucoup d'informatique
je considère qu'il faut faire attention
de la multiplication des projets pour
pourra les mener à bien dans le temps et
dans les coups qu'elle en a trop en
général c'est un peu plus difficile
je ne peux malheureusement pas une
excuse à répondre soit la question
d'amadeus pour 20 pour une raison simple
si je vous disais que je garde que que
je voulais augmenter la participation le
court d'amadeus montrait je ferai donc
une très mauvaise affaire
et si je vous disais que j'allais vendre
le quad abu dhabi ou s'effondrerait dont
je ferai aussi une très mauvaise affaire
dont je veux tu être ne pas un pro sur
cette question simplement un point le
plan de transformation qui donc porte
sur 2 milliards 9 pour le pour le groupe
air france klm 2 milliards pour air
france nous permet de rétablir notre
capacité financière sans avoir à faire
de désinvestissements ça c'est un point
qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit
sauf cas de force majeure mais qui ne se
présente pas pour l'instant donc le 6ème
nous avions à faire un quelconque
investissement il serait plutôt destiné
à financer une opération
d'investissement ailleurs mais il se
fait sans cela donc je je je m'excuse
d'avancé ne pas avoir pu répondre très
précisément à amadeus mais j'espère que
la commission de comprendre à sur le low
cost pourquoi est ce que nous avons du
mal comme toutes les compagnies
d'ailleurs toutes les compagnies
historiques à lutter contre low cost
il ya plusieurs raisons d'abord le low
cost s'est bâti sur un modèle
bakou pas de service qui s'adresse à une
clientèle pour lequel le prix est
important et seulement le prix et elle
s'est bâtie sur un deuxième modèle
géographique et le modèle point à point
les locaux avaient remarqué fond la
desserte d'une ville à l'autre
indépendamment des correspondances nous
une très très grosse partie de notre de
notre réseau court et moyen-courrier
alimente le hub les hubs de roissy et de
ce qu'ils peuvent pour pour pour ensuite
pour ensuite alimenter notre réseau
international
donc c'est une contrainte que les low
cost non pas du tout nous offrons nous
un service tout compris
voir avec un prix qui est peut-être un
peu plus élevé mais si vous regardez
vraiment tout ce qu'on paye sur une low
cost pour le même service vous
apercevrez très souvent notamment si
vous voulez partir au jour où c'est un
peu plus encombré c'est toujours la même
chose je me suis porté le mardi à 14
heures ou le vendredi à 18 heures on n'a
pas tout à fait le même prix vous êtes
assuré que le cumul des suppléments
demandé par les locos dépasse assez
souvent et je crois que le test vient
d'être publiquement sur un paris milan
le prix offert par air france ou par l
italien intéressant donc alors comment
ce qu'on cherche à ceux à lutter contre
cela et puis euh pardon troisième quart
était assez des low cost ils ont opéré
avec des conditions économiques et
sociales qui sont beaucoup plus beaucoup
moins cher que les compagnies
historiques soit parce qu'ils sont là
ils sont plus jeunes ils sont
immatriculés en général dans des pays où
les houles et où les coûts sociaux
notamment sont moins élevés ils ont une
flotte plus jeune il opine ils n'ont ans
où ils n'ont souvent pas de deux
personnels au sol ils font simplement
appel au personnel au sol qui existe et
qui est fournie soit pas l'aéroport soit
pas des compagnies soit par d'autres
compagnies
donc leur structure de coûts est
extrêmement basse ce qui n'est pas notre
cas recommence que nous
le ton qu'on soit on lutte et nous avons
fait les bases province
en demandant un effort de productivité
importants acceptés négocié par les
personnels et qui est d'ailleurs un
véritable succès notamment un succès
social je ne je n'ai pas rencontré dans
l'ensemble d'air france pourtant les
personnages sont attachés à la maison de
jean plus attachés aux plus motivés que
la base de marseille
c'est très très remarquable qui est donc
notre première base de deux provinces
nous avons aussi peut-être à réfléchir à
opérer une partie des lignes à partir
d'une compagnie qui serait différent
peut-être filiale d'air france nous en
avons déjà eu une s'appelle transavia
com vous le savez qui serait peut-être
qu'il faut se répéter sur le modèle des
low cost et y avait quelque chose à
regarder
voilà donc voilà comment nous nous nous
allons essayer d'opérer ce marché en
ayant dans l'idée la chose suivante
c'est que nous pensons qu'à deux
segments de marché et le segment des
gens pour lequel le prix est absolument
clé qui sera opéré par quelque chose qui
ressemble à des low cost et par le et
par un système low cost et puis un
segment de marché des gens qui sont
prêts à payer
sachant que ces segments évolué dans le
temps et ne sont pas les mêmes en
fonction des lignes
vous imaginez bien que le segment des
gens qui ce qu'ils sont prêts à payer
est plus fort sur des six nations il ya
beaucoup de passage et e-business 1 que
que que des saignements touristique
c'est ça le le le est-ce que nous allons
trop vite pour notre prono négociations
sociales
je veux pas lire ici qu'on est de
construire sur nos intentions
il s'agit pas de confondre vitesse et
précipitation mais il s'agit quand même
d'aboutir à une négociation que nous
espérons la meilleure possible dans les
délais qui ne sont pas les délais
habituels de la maison qui a tout petit
peu disons qui prend son temps
voilà et je pense moi j'ai rien contre
le fait de prendre le temps sauf le fait
que nous sommes nous sommes
malheureusement sur une contrainte
financière qui ne le permet pas je pense
et je crois d'ailleurs que les
partenaires sociaux ou en tout cas une
partie d'entre eux sont convaincus de
l'exigence de vitesse et d'urgence est
ce que nous faisons très attention aux
questions de délocalisations
industrielles
oui nous faisons extrêmement attention à
ce sujet là nos personnels d'ailleurs
ils font aussi extrêmement attention
donc voilà c'est un sujet évidemment
nous gérons
mm et que nous gérons d'ailleurs avec
l'idée de remplir et de charger pour
reprendre l'expression industriels les
ateliers levin que nous avons en france
en priorité évidemment dans ces
investissements considérables pour
encore une fois je le dis à un outil
industriel qui est d'une qualité
remarquable qui agissent
d'investissements énormes s'agirait pas
de de ne pas charger cesser cet outil
industriel
l'avenir du que le le l'avenir du cargo
alors le cargo et un est une est une
activité qui est important dans une
compagnie comme air france klm
nous opérons un peu 15 avions tout cargo
10 pour qu'elle aime près 5 pour air
france ce sont nos deux bases de ce qui
est de charles de gaulle et de ce qu'ils
peuvent le cargo est dans une situation
difficile pour pour une raison c'est
comme vous savez c'est un indicateur
avancé la conjoncture économique
c'est le cargo est très très très
élastique à la conjoncture
quand ça va bien le cargo va très très
bien mais très mal donc en ce moment je
dois reconnaître qu'avec le
ralentissement du second semestre 2011
on est restés sont difficiles donc il ya
tout un plan de restauration de la
compétitivité du cargo sur les deux
bases de ski paul charles de gaulle et
avec le souci de me d'essayer de
maintenir une activité cargo dynamique
sachez quand même pour la pour votre
information c'est que nous avons non
seulement la concurrence est le maritime
mais qu'on a la mise en place de
capacités considérables sur l'asie par
des compagnies chinoises
donc elle met des capacités cargo
évidemment ça fait ça fait s'effondrer
des prix et bizarrement manière
intéressante d'ailleurs fait 13 presque
paradoxal dans les derniers mois les
exportations europe verra s'ils se sont
maintenus mais les importations asie
vers europe se sont effondrés notamment
hong kong l'europe qui était une des
links à rouler le plus dynamique cc
c'est assez paradoxal je le dire mais
c'est à ces d'un constat que nous aurons
secteur géographique est ce que nous
allons modifier nos sites d'orly de
toulouzette valbonne la réponse est non
ont ils sont ils restent telles qu'elles
orly va être le centre de notre réseau
point à point en plus un sur l'escale
d'orly
va être le centre de notre raison pour
un point cette année maillon important
de la réforme de notre réseau court et
moyen courrier avec les bases de
province ça va puis fait le coeur de
notre raison pour un point et 2 et des
compagnies régionales également les
dividendes eux deux sur les cinq
dernières années nous avons distribué 0
dividendes sur les dix dernières parts
dont vous êtes je n'ai pas le chiffre en
tête et je crois que c'est extrêmement
limité je l'appelle souviens c'était
tout à fait habsi l'honneur
il faut remonter très loin pourtant il
doit retrouver un dividende ce qui est
d'ailleurs que ce sera axée d'après
actionnaires publics un problème puisque
si on veut un jour attirer les nouveaux
actionnaires de la france
il faudrait qu'on puisse temps en temps
leurs fruits puisque 18 dividendes je
crois ce serait pas déplacé et que et
compte tenu du caractère risqué et
cyclique du secteur de la de l'aérien on
nettoie ses il faut avoir aussi quelques
arguments pardon sonnant et trébuchant
pour pouvoir pour que les pardonne à des
actionnaires et les leurs fonds puissent
venir chez nous l'avenir du capital moi
je me prononce pas sur le fait que
l'état monte ou descend il m'appartient
pas de me prononcer sur cette question
le capital de la maison moi je trouve
qu'il doit servir à deux choses s'il
peut servir à nouer des partenariats
c'est une très bonne chose c'est dans le
fond ce que nous avons fait klm c'est
une excellente chose
voilà ci ne peut nous servir à faire des
opérations financières avec notre propre
monnaie
c'est une excellente chose et cela qu'il
faut que cette mode elles valent quelque
chose elle va le plus possible et
troisièmement nous sommes très
favorables à air france si les
opérations dans le passé et est à re
développer l'actionnariat salarié très
très très favorable c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs si je puis me permettre ce
trait mais le fait d'avoir une action
qui n'est dont le cours n'est pas très
élevé à tous les inconvénients de la
terre sauf un c'est que le fait de
distribuer aux salariés leur donne une
perspective d'augmentation le futur
pourquoi avoir fait un plan en deux
temps
c'est cette question a été à est
effectivement relevé plusieurs fois et
l'interférence avec les échéances
politiques également
je vous prie de croire
alors que l'interférence cette échéance
politique est un élément de 2e ou de 3e
rang l'élément fondamental c'est le
premier temps représente plus de la
moitié du plan le premier temps dans ses
cages aux lycéens milliards 2 sur 2
milliards pour la france donc c'est la
partie financièrement la plus
substantielle du plan deuxièmement le
deuxième temps est fondé sur sur sur
deux points qui qui qui qui exigent pour
nous de travailler
nous devons travailler le modèle
économique restructuration du clos du
moyen-courrier amélioration du long
courrier
il y à des semaines de travail que nous
voulons mener en accord avec les
salariés pour être sûr qu'ils adhèrent
qui comprennent les enjeux qu'ils
adhèrent aux solutions que nous
proposons
ça se fait pas en deux jours pardon mais
je vais faire moi je ne sais pas le
faire en deux jours je voulais et nous
avons prévu
rien que pour le constat et pour
l'identification des pistes de travail
et deux mois et demi nous serons prêts
fin mars
et je trouve que c'est déjà rapide
deuxièmement 7 sur la base de ce nouveau
modèle économique seront à renégocier
les accords que les partenaires sociaux
dans le cadre de la nouvelle politique
contractuelle combien en place cette
négociation on a veut rapide elle ne
peut pas non plus ou sinon alors je veux
que je n'ai pas compris où on risque
d'être taxé de précipitations que que
cette négociation se fasse dans les
délais et qui soit excessivement court
d'ailleurs si on veut préciser ces deux
temps j'ai dit au début qu'elle était
l'objet de nos négociations nous avons
dans un premier temps les mesures
d'urgence que j'appellerais unilatéral
c'est ce qu'ils disposent pas
dénonciation d'accords et dans un
deuxième temps à partir du 10 février
donc à partir de vendredi une
information pour une possible initiation
d accord et après il ya tout le temps de
la négociation qui nous l'espérons doit
se dérouler le plus rapidement possible
ne sommes pas maîtres de ce que sera
l'issue
dans le temps des négociations avec les
partenaires sociaux dont les deux temps
sans simplement une modification je
dirais juridique de ce qu'est
le l'effort social accomplir dans le
domaine social c'est ça est ce que la
volonté d'être premier mondial fait
l'objet d'une feinte résulte d'un rêve
une volonté de puissance inadapté qui ne
serait pas c'est pas du tout le cas je
crois qu'il ya deux raisons pour
laquelle être dans les premiers mondiaux
est important la première c'est que nous
sommes dans une industrie qui est
capitalistiquement très très intenses
l'industrie c'est paradoxalement une
industrie de services à très forte
intensité capitalistique et donc en
général dans les très fortes l'industrie
doivent pas des industries à forte
intensité capitalistique la
concentration et l'économie d'échelle et
était absolument essentiel donc c'est
pour ça donc ça pousse à la croissance
deuxièmement nous avons été premier
mondial injuste que ya trois ans donc
c'est ce n'est pas ce n'est pas le rêve
ou le ou là où l'illusion de que de que
de vouloir y revenir
troisièmement la force du réseau à air
france klm c'est ça c'est son
développement à thalassa son déploiement
international
si nous voulons tirer parti de la
croissance future qui se fera plutôt
dans des zones hors europe qu'en europe
je crois qu'on a intérêt à croître soit
pas de partenariat soit par des
acquisitions soit parfois toute mesure
possible dans ces pays là ce qui exige
ou dans ces zones là ce qui existe pour
nous de grossir voilà cc c'est ça qui
motive le projet que nous avons proposé
aux personnels et à la compagnie est ce
que l'effort soit partagé par tous oui
d'abord à toutes les catégories de
personnel on va demander un effort est
ce qu'il sera partagé par la la la
catégorie des de la direction
certainement oui
nous avons pour la direction générale
par exemple réduit l'enveloppent de
parts variables de en moyenne 17,1 rsa
de moitié pour moi c'est la même chose
ici puisque le blues mais ce qui
correspond à une réduction de 25% propre
rémunération nous avons supprimé un
certain nombre davantage liés aux postes
de direction et nous sommes en train de
réfléchir là à la manière dont nous
attribuons un certain nombre d'
avantages qu'ils étaient liés
historiquement ad'ailleurs terme de
billets et de ses billets gratuits de
voyages dans des classes supérieures
nouvel ajournement les classes
inférieures
ça me parait d'air
fait normal ça va de soi l'exemplarité
je vous suis tout à fait sûr ce vin
commence par le au jeu de rappeler à ce
sujet que je disais au début nous avons
un rythme d'évolution des salaires qui
est sensiblement trop élevé cdja
l'ensemble aux accords si on prend les
cent dernières années lançant du
personnel hormis les cadres dirigeants à
une augmentation de salaire qui a été
comprise entre 3 et 3 et demi pour cent
par an sur les cinq années les cadres
dirigeants ont eu sur quatre ans un
blocage de salaire sur les cinq ans et
pour le reste la baisse de rémunération
ses résultats cette année de la
réduction par deux dernières sont
variables et de 17%
dernier point sur l'intégration avec klm
donc l'intégration avec klm elle en est
à un stade où une partie des fonctions
est intégrée tout tout le réseau
international est intégrée
l'informatique est intégrée la finance
est en cours d'intégration et va
d'ailleurs être transféré au groupe la
direction financière par société
manipulations financières groupe il ya
un certain nombre encore d'étapes à
franchir mais sachez que l'intégration
totale des deux compagnies est un peu
difficile puisque chacune au père de ses
deux robes avec ses personnels localisés
dans chacun de ses oeuvres monopuce nous
ne voyons pas de sens particulier à
intégrer par exemple tous les pnc où
tous les pilotes outre que les règles
sociales sont très différentes que les
avantages respectifs ou que les
contraintes respectives d'aidé à des
catégories de personnel sur les deux
pays ne sont pas les mêmes et que il
n'apparaît pas nécessaire de les aligner
si je passe deux ans le ferai mais il
n'apparaît pas nécessaire de le faire
donc l'intégration se poursui c'est vrai
que pour l'instant la priorité est le
l'accent a été mis sur les mesures de
redressement financier des deux
compagnies je le confesse humblement et
donc cette intégration se poursuit mais
à un rythme qui a qui est un peu ralenti
il il n'empêche qu'à l'horizon 2014 un
certain nombre de fonctions
supplémentaires ont été intégré dans la
holding air france klm pour les deux
pour les deux compagnies elle n'est pas
du tout au point mort ce intégration car
nous avons des direction jointe je pense
à l'industrie je pense à l'informatique
je pense à l'international donc
je pense au cargö donc l'essentiel des
grands direction de la compagnie et est
maintenant jointe entre les deux
compagnies merci monsieur le président
d'abord d'avoir distrait cette période
de fin de matinée pour vous faire
auditionner vous avez bien vu le nombre
de questions je conçois que vous avez en
ce moment des préoccupations à la fois
vis-à-vis de négociations mais aussi
bien sûr concernant l'ensemble de la
compagnie et son avenir
dans tous les cas je vous souhaite bon
vol si j'ose dire
pour la suite des opérations merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
merci de votre attention
voilà pour cette audition du pdg d'air
france merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
pour la revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr très belle journée à tous